on va faire un petit tour de table sur
les mers d'accord il ya une mère qu'il
appelle tous les jours pour lui donner
son avis sur l'émission sur sa carrière
vianney aussi votre maman elle l est
elle est très présente ouais mais pas
tous les jours ben vous n'avez pas tous
les autres tout moche c'est vrai non ah
ouais by naim mois - carmen la mer
abbaoui away maman s'appelle tous les
jours c'est vrai se parle de la vie de
l'émission de vous oui ce qu'il veut bah
vous si vous aime bien mais je pense que
votre mère et je rigole pas bon je pense
qu'elle aurait qui fait que vous soyez
avec moi ah bon ouais je pense c'est un
des grands malheurs de sa vie comme ça
mais à la fin c'est comme ma grande
soeur en a b c qu'est ce qui a donc sa
mère est folle aussi merci vous êtes
très drôle votre maman vous à peine non
elles ne veulent pas tous les jours et
je l'appelle pas tous les jours mais
quand elle m'appelle me fait ces
commentaires pas sur les missions mais
sur moi dans les mythes sur elle vous
dit quoi sur moi étaient maquillés comme
ça pourquoi cette coiffure pour pourquoi
tu dis ta gueule parce que j'ai été
élevé comme ça
mais voilà donc ces c'est mignon je
t'adore non mais elle est encore là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas comme avec sa maman elle est
bien là encore de sous mais monsieur
webb vous votre mère vous appelez moi
même surtout elle ne convainc que parce
qu'on habite dans le même immeuble
ah ouais alors jouer alors vous
connaissez pas c'est la dynastie vdo
venez là bas où elle habite sa banlieue
ces gens il ya un immeuble il ya marqué
v2v sont mamans papas au quatrième les
cous entre les pays tu peux venir au
cinquième maman ta peine
la dynastie médard il s'incline 12 quoi
sert elle me combat quand j'ai déconné
là bas je vais dans son appartement
gaver vous dit quoi tu étais trop gros
ce soir tu étais trop vulgaire
territoire de gueuler et arrête de crier
trop fort non
en tout cas regarde l'émission ça fait
plaisir je rigole ça arrive et je rigole
c'est qu'ils a préféré son préféré je
dirais non papa me nous dire elle aime
beaucoup valérie shawey et benjamins à
toutes les personnes un peu âgées vous
et je vous jure c'est vrai mais vous
vous faites des vous devriez aller faire
des galettes des rois dans les maisons
de retraite qui est maire qui faisait
fantasmer tous et tous ses copains vous
alors alors c'est quoi alors à quelle
époque
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais ça va changer tour et que c'est
qu'il fut mon tour mais comme c'est pas
une question que de physique ma mère
fait fantasmer les fans parce que c'est
vrai et vous mais vous aussi un temps
moi je vous auriez tu es ma mère mes
copains et ferries qui s'est dit non
mais non mais sérieux et pierre-jean
dans vous non ma mère non merci fait
fantasmer c'est vrai quoi qui vint
madame alors c'est pas vrai les choses
oui parce qu'elle est elle n y fait un
carnage en ce moment au la police était
mais sa peau ni elle passait dans les
rues qui avaient été les mets qui les
connaissent pas s'entraîner comme ça
dans la neige vous une stat truc de ouf
à la police là on s'est rendu compte
peut alors vous êtes très modifiée non
laponie mon frère s'est elle passée
votre style
j'adore alors voilà côté joséphine baker
oui oui c'est vrai ah ouais moi je
propose un sac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
juste n'est pas d'épée fait fatah j'ai
pas de problème avec le sexe en ce
moment sur des temps sophie davant bien
sûr d'aller jeter alors non mais je vous
dis abondamment ces mamies vous avez
tous au vaccin je suis maintenant je dis
ça parce que avec avec la peau ni mon
avis non la laponie s'est très bien
passé mais comme à la manger des trucs
un peu chelou
[Applaudissements]
c'est une affaire conclue mais alors pas
qu'il faille oui ça sera avec
seize ans au calme je sais pas pourquoi
je sens que comme thibaut loire
embrasser bas gagner des années va faire
mais il n'est pas là il est où
[Applaudissements]
non mais non mais c'est vrai que c'est
par ailleurs vous votre mère donc vous
appelle on était dans les cales faisait
fantasmer les copains vous benhaim non
si ma mère si nassimah n'en voyons vous
n'ont pas trop vous permet aux personnes
un caractère un peu tremblé quand même
ah ouais ouais mais mes copains m'ont
rien dit mais je suis sûr qu'ils
devaient fantasmer ce qu'est c'était une
blonde aux yeux verts absolument
magnifique bas les chiens font pas des
chats manet avec nathalie et sony mais
alors qui a une mère qui lui donne un
petit surnom bien pourri jusque dans le
film fanny ardant surnomme vianney bon
ben hammam mon baboo un donc vous mettez
pas votre surnom benji mois mais gi's
sont pas fait chier c'était portes
ouvertes a dit moi c'était ma grand'mère
sexy oui oui mais c'était très
affectueux monsieur iduma grande mais
merci quoi vianney dans la vie vraiment
c'est vous avez un sur nenê nenê moi
j'aurais dit vie ouais mais les gens qui
y vivent y est tous mes parents et que
vous venez le charcutier nenê charcuter
frère tu vas sexy fait d'un mortadelle
ou quoi il paraît que ça me saoulait
quand j'étais petit
ah ouais donc mais j'aime bien moi je
tapais comme sané des charcuteries mais
maintenant tu veux et tu es pas obligé
beinheim ses couvertures non non il
m'appelait val a way back en mai 75 de
faire c'est peut-être pouvez-vous mois
pour d'autres raisons c'est déjà le king
à l'époque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sequana blair a pu m'appeler maximus
venus des grandes marques à maxime
usines et qu sa table mais ça ils
parlaient alors on l'attend à l'aller au
togo lycos a tous été très rares ah oui
une fois par an vous comment vous
appelez moi on m'appelait babette à ce
que le surnom d' isabelle à l'époque
c'était belle et comme je l'étais
franchement pas on n'a pas voulu
l'humilier et met à l'achat faut qu'elle
parte sur la dîme à leur embarquement au
ps aurait volé mais si on est chez
mireille dumas n'est qu'elle va faire on
a une larve cammas qui tombe d'une
nicolas pernikoff le rappel c'était le
king de france télé 1 milliard au
troisième est pas un projet du trust
très sympa c'est mon grand mais vu mon
gros bébé ses revenus
christine watine ticino et toi marc bébé
tout simplement qui vous appellent bébé
mais ma mère m'appelait bébé ah oui et
vous père jean mois titi et étoiles
gilles g ou bus gilou bus et aux bus je
sais pas fallu demander notamment valu
une vraie série et vous moi kitty natkin
antibiotiques